[Musique]
bonsoir c'est quoi ce bordel mais vous
êtes qui ouais tu me connais voilà bah
si tu me connais moi je te connais je
connais ta petite chaîne youtube parc à
la capte assez mon truc aussi je filme
je filme je pensais avoir tout le matos
qu'il faut et la une raide komodo
si tu sais quoi françois
mais qui a aucun moyen de sortir d'ici
tu va m'expliquer en quoi
[Musique]
il ya un truc que je pige pas pas plus
tard que la semaine dernière j'ai filmé
la kermesse de ma nièce avec une canne
je connais ça sony fuji nikon olympus
à dax
mais raide
pourquoi
brasse pas compliqué
après tu sais parmi les caméras les plus
prestigieuses c'est des caméras de
cinéma ou de séries netflix stranger
tides house of cards sastourné à la
reine reste une marque tout jeune
comparé à des constructeurs historiques
leur première caméra est sorti en 2007
sous le nom de red one c'est d'ailleurs
eux qui ont eu le privilège de sortir la
première caméra numérique capable de
filmer en 4k ici on ne parle pas
d'appareil photo qui font de la vidéo
mais devrait caméra de cinéma étudier et
design et pour la fiction le clip et
c'est parfait pour bloguer quoi et de
nombreux grands réalisateurs se sont
d'ailleurs servi de caméras est au
cinéma steven soderbergh david fincher
ou même peter jackson qui a réalisé le
hobbit avec une red epic raid est
surtout connu pour avoir été dans le lot
des précurseurs de la caméra numérique
attends tu es en train de me dire tu
veux te lancer dans le cinéma
ben non non non bien sûr que non ça ça
mérite qui était abonné laisse un
commentaire et lâche un petit pouce
bleus la cour modo c'est la petite soeur
de ces grosses caméras de signer niveau
form factor c'est pas du tout la même
chose et puis question prix on est très
très loin des grosses caméras
d'hollywood tient le vent factor
puisqu'on en parle on est sur une toute
petite caméra dont le corps se présente
sous la forme d'un cube de 10 cm d'arrêt
parce qu'à la base cette caméra elle
répondait à un besoin des studios de
cinéma avoir une crash calmes c'est à
dire une petite caméra qui craint rien
et qui match avec les grosses caméras de
signer la gopro c'est sympa mais c'est
pas le même qu'à ériger une énorme
caméra sur une voiture ça doit être
chiant voir dans
là on a une petite caméra de 1 kg bon
une fois accessoirisé c'est un peu plus
mais tu vois l'idée donc en fait t'as
raid c'est juste une gopro assimile bull
comme un punk eut sorti mon petit coin
non je disais tu avais presque la bonne
réponse ouais c'est ça mais continue il
ne faut pas ma gueule à l'arrière on a
deux logements de batterie et on peut
faire un changement sans éteindre la
caméra si l'une des deux est évident
comme support d'enregistrement on a des
cartes ses fastes au dessus on a un
écran lcd tactile
bon il est pas fou fou faut l'admettre
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai
opté pour un moniteur qui lui aussi est
tactile et qui commande les
fonctionnalités de la caméra je récupère
le contrôle via un câble est d'ailleurs
en parlant de câbles pas de hdmi
c'est du s10 ike et une connectique
beaucoup plus pro soit dit en passant
pour moi qui n'ai jamais eu de caméras
de ce type entre les mains j'ai trouvé
les menus vraiment intuitif d'une
simplicité déconcertante par rapport à
ce que j'avais connu du côté des
boîtiers photo mais dans tous les cas il
ya d'autres moyens vraiment cool d'avoir
en retour
si on regarde bien il ya cette petite
antenne wifi et on peut connecter une
tablette ou un smartphone et s'en servir
de moniteur
on peut même contrôler la caméra avec
l'avs est hyper bien fait et fonctionnel
et on peut tous pilotés à distance que
ce soit la mise au point l'ouverture les
iso tout et c'est plutôt pas mal non
pour le son on a droit à une entrée et
une sortie mini jack
l'une pour brancher un micro à l'autre
pour mettre un casque il ya aussi un
micro intégré mais c'est plus pour avoir
une piste témoins et synchronisée du
sombre que pour enregistrer réellement
niveau accessoirisation il ya un truc
très cool qui la démarque des autres
caméras red c'est qu'on n'est pas obligé
d'utiliser uniquement des accessoires
propriétaire
[Musique]
tu peux pas t'empêcher de ramener ta
science même quand t'es dans la merde
samedi toujours pas pourquoi tu as
acheté ça le capteur
la meilleure partie seul capteur c'est
une des grandes forces de ré de la color
cnc ou fait on est sur une plage
dynamique de plus de seize diaf avec un
capteur 6 cas au format super 35
tu plaisantes là c'est même pas du plein
format ouais enfin si tu savais le
nombre de blockbusters qui ont été
tournées avec format super 35 personnes
n'a jamais fait une pendule quoi ouais
continue je disais donc on est sur un
capteur super 35 de 19 points 9
mégapixels qui bénéficie du savoir-faire
de chez red et qui n'a strictement rien
à envier à ses grandes soeurs de la même
marque
la couleur silent basse et red quoi
c'est ouf les tempos sont incroyables
l'image est douce même avec des optiques
piqué tout a un look différent des cas
voir les images que j'ai shooté avec ses
incroyables en termes de framerate on
peut faire jusqu'à 50 images par seconde
en 6 cas et jusqu'à 120 images par
seconde en deux cas mais avec un sacré
creux
le truc avec cette caméra c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on réduira la définition
on croquera dans le capteur elle est
donc pas vraiment fait pour les accros
au slow motion
mais la sica à 50 fps c'est quand même
sacrément cool
en tout cas pour moi c'est largement
suffisant ni vos montures on est sur les
nouvelles montures cannon les r f
mais la caméra est fourni avec une bague
pour y adapter les optiques en monture e
f
d'ailleurs il ya deux bacs cannon super
sympa qu'on peut y ajouter une avec un
filtre end est intégré et un speed
booster pour retrouver le look plein
format et tant qu'on est sur le capteur
baïla ce qu'on appelle un global shooter
et ça c'est franchement pas mal
sur la plupart des boîtiers photos qui
font de la vidéo on a ce qu'on appelle
un rolling thunder
c'est à dire que l'image est scanné
ligne par ligne de gauche à droite et on
l'a tous expérimentés quand il ya du
mouvement ça donne un effet de
déformation aveux comme de la gelée et
c'est super inesthétiques
le global j'adore lui capture l'image
d'un seul coup donc quand tu fais de la
stabilisation en post prod c'est juste
dingue est clairement ça ces
cinématiques ça ça va donner un bien à
part un truc imperceptible mais qui
change tout j'avoue j'ai pas tout
compris mais c'est un gars cool t'as pas
vu meilleur quoi je sais pas si tu te
rappelles mais on avait parlé du projet
zéro et a pas si longtemps sur la chaîne
bon bah là on est largement au dessus le
raid code c'est le codec frau de raids
et c'est un des meilleurs du marché
c'est quand même dur aux 16 bits et le
raid que doit capter les informations
indépendamment de l'espace
colorimétrique
en gros l'idée c'est qu'on va pouvoir
capter un max d'infos mais j'ai vraiment
énormément et une fois devant l'ordi on
peut gérer les iso la balance des blancs
le gamma gamut bref c'est leur rêve pour
les tableaux et c'est d'une simplicité
déconcertante pour peu qu'on est bien
exposé la scène le rendu est tout de
suite cinématographique
et oui là je le dis sans mettre des
guillemets ont par contre les fichiers
sont gigantesques pour te donner une
idée sur ma carte de 512 giga
j'enregistre environ 1h30 en six cas
mais ce qui m'a vraiment déstabilisé sur
cette caméra sait à quel point elle est
pensée pour la vidéo principalement pour
la fiction tout est accessible
facilement les outils des de
l'exposition sont vraiment très bien
pensé et tout est beau avec le confort
et la facilité d'utilisation sont
impressionnants
françois dix mois que la f10 chertouh
ouais alors lève déjà y en a 1 1 ce qui
est pas hyper courant sur les caméras de
signer c'est juste une détection de
contraste
il n'ya pas de suivi de sujet ou de
tracking mais grosso modo en exagérant
un peu on pourrait dire que c'est pas
loin d'un autofocus panasonic il ya
forcément un truc qui va pas c'est trop
beau pour être vrai ça peut pas être si
parfait oui bah pour le capteur pour la
couleur sayan serait il ya forcément des
cons premier à faire justement c'est
pour ça je me dis c'est peut-être pas
pour toi t'es pas du genre à faire des
compromis
bon l'écran intégré on a déjà parlé je
veux pas revenir dessus mais vraiment
c'est pas de la folie c'est pas réactif
l'emplacement au dessus est très mal
choisi bref ya aussi pas de double
logement pour les cartes donc même si
ces deux-là s'effacer que c'est fiable
ya pas de bac
la commande n'est pas aussi run and gun
qu'un boîtier mural est d'ailleurs c'est
pas du tout le même usage même si pour
une raide c'est quand même une caméra
qu'on pourra set up plutôt rapidement
pour te donne une idée s'allumer environ
30 secondes
il faut qu'elle se mette en température
mais bon vous relativisez d'autres raids
peuvent mettre plusieurs minutes à
démarrer elle est aussi pensé pour
filmer canton contrôler sa lumière et
même si elle reste à gilles les
variations environnement en rapide ou de
température force à l aime pas vraiment
elle nécessite aussi du temps de réglage
on a par exemple le blog shading c'est à
dire la calibration des noirs à faire à
chaque fois qu'on change d'environnement
et qu'il ya un changement notable de
température la connectique est limitée
bref c'est quand même une caméra de
niche c'est pas pour tous les usages
hop là comme au dos et une caméra
incroyable avec des spex totalement
dingue et un rendu bluffant mais ça
reste une caméra de compromis le croque
dans le capteur quand on veut faire du
solomo indique qu'elle est pas vraiment
fait pour ça le poids des fichiers le
temps nécessaire à la mise en å tout ça
fait que c'est une caméra qui n'est pas
faite pour tous les usages et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que le set 6-2 va
rester ma caméra de tous les jours mais
quand on voit l'image
quand on voit également que c'est une
caméra qui peut être géré par un seul
opérateur
ça donne envie de faire des concessions
quand tu dis qu'elle est pas pour moi
c'est à dire peu développé un peu parce
que j'ai peur de mal comprendre
ouais non non on fait ce que je voulais
dire c'est je pensais pas que tu étais à
ce point professionnel tu vois je me
suis dit rapport à l'écran intégré la f
la niche aniche j'adore serre émis
chaque mois
tu entends je peux être très clair ça
ça tu veux
j'écoute mord les mollets
tu entends je peux te voir de la monnaie
tu veux je te montre je te montre ah
ouais c'est ça
j'ai dit qu'on pouvait passer
hamon
[Musique]
encore paquet truc tout va m'expliquer